all right let's see if we can make some
sense of this first we convert 64
kilobytes into bytes by multiplying by
thousand 24 bytes which is 65536 bytes
next we convert this number into the
number of packets by dividing by the
size of the packet and that turns out to
be approximately 45 packets next we can
plug in the numbers that we have into
the formula that we have here we know
that the round-trip time is 100
milliseconds we have 45 packets that we
need to transfer and the initial
congestion window is 10 packets now this
actually simplifies to 3 so what we
actually have is 100 milliseconds times
3 or approximately 300 milliseconds but
Ilya I have a question for you why do
these brackets look weird this is
actually the ceiling function which
means that you need to round up the
number to the next greatest integer once
you figure out the answer to this log
function thank you so the final answer
is 300 milliseconds which is quite a bit
of time that's that note that this is
only true for new to speak connections
check the link in the instructor notes
for more details